the state pension age down
nope
sorry sorry grandpa and grandma
but we are not going to do that actually
The Netherlands is getting grayer
and we have to pay for that together
we have to be careful that people who start young
with heavy work
that we make sure they can keep it up
and that they are also helped in this
in time 1 ban on anonymous twittering
oh yes that's 1 good idea
I think 1 good idea to shower cold
yes,
but not always
but it is actually 1 very tasty
feeling when you do it again
no no nursing home
good care
free public transport
free no
but affordable
yes and that is what the Christian Union has committed itself to
past budget
420 million extra
not only that you can afford the ticket
but also that De Bus continues to drive
because in too many places
for example,
it stops at 6 o'clock in the evening
and then you have all the consequences
that should not build houses in nature reserves
in nature reserves
not in nature reserves
but I do find every village
every city should get 1 street